hey everybody and welcome to another
episode of allegedly I'm Matthew Cole
Weiss and today because our normal co
host Theo von is in New York probably
banging someone or doing something we
have a special guest host mr. Jeff
Schroeder how's it going you may know
Jeff from Big Brother Big Brother 8 12
15 17 whatever raise 3 9 whatever and he
hosts the Big Brother after-show so
what's up man you just when the road
rules people aren't here you go to CBS
reality stars and then I'm out these are
the people who are readily available
you have vh1 so out there so you still
have a couple of people but yeah man
it's awesome to be here I listen to your
show I'm a big fan and we have we have
our special guest today is Lance Bass
another honor to be here also we'll be
on a new reality show as well hosting so
I can't wait to hear about that but
first while we're in it I want to ask
you since Big Brother's going on right
now like who's your pick to win it you
know well let me put it this way my
first pick to win I don't know if
there's any Big Brother fans out there
my first pick to be voted out first was
Paul and surprisingly pretty pretty
quickly I jumped on Paul's
bandwagon and I picked him to win now
and I think he has the best shot but
with the way things are going now you
never know in that crazy house what
could happen but I think he's got the
tools to win it all right now but you
never know what's gonna and when you
talk to these people when they come out
of the house is it like they came out of
a bunker like shell-shocked like is it
weird me so I got this 40-day rule thing
so I played twice and I know how it is
in there and the second time I really
learned so after 40 days I don't think
whatever situation you're in your mind
adapts to so I definitely see a change
in them just watching them on TV and
especially when they come out and talk
to me our latest evicted houseguest was
Paulie so Paulie don't like him any more
as a player to be honest cuz he was
really mean to Zakia and I thought it
was just like True Colors douchey but
he's he's a pretty boy what was he like
to interview the interview I got to be
honest with you like Paulie was out
there man I was asking him questions and
he was answering a question I asked
three questions ago and I just asked him
a simple like give me one name
thinks gonna win I think there's two
people I think there's three hold on
like his mind was grinding you could
just see it in his face and his answers
in his mind he was her tonight I didn't
want to make him cry it's not that my
type of show or my interview if someone
cries well there was a scene where
there's this butterfly oh you see the
butterfly scene and he thought it was
I'm so fake
this amend so we rigged a studio with a
butterfly that was gonna drop listen we
I thought he's gonna be like you know
like take it well you know it backfired
man backfired bet so we dropped the fake
butterfly and he kind of played it off
and I saw like in his face he didn't
like it so I was like okay great
they dropped it again in like two
minutes and I was like dude get that
butterfly out of here so I saw he was
like welling up a little bit so I kind
of got off the subject and then at the
end I always give somebody a gift and
this time it was a mug and attached to
the mug somebody attached a butterfly so
we beat this butterfly story to death
that I felt so terrible for him so again
I think the house just breaks you down
and I think it really got the best of
them and he just doesn't know it yet so
I think jury house is good for Paulie
right now now before we get to our
guests I want to ask one more thing cuz
you are half of Jeff and Jordan which is
one of the most famous couples to come
out of Big Brother and you were recently
married and you are having a baby all of
it man how is life going right now and
you're what two months from having a kid
- yeah October 20th is a due date so we
just went to the doctor yesterday got a
check-up everything's perfect eight
weeks out now which is crazy I just
painted the baby's room quote-unquote
the baby's quarter because we have a
one-bedroom apartment so I got a quarter
painted and it's cute though we got all
of our stuff we had a baby shower in
Chicago Jordan was just back in
Charlotte for a little baby shower so it
was just it was just great so true that
if it's a girl you're naming her Julie
and if it's a guy you're naming him less
for sure this big brother brother owned
your baby they do what we signed when we
first get on the show you do sign your
first child away so they own they own
the first day own so it's up to them
what they want to name it Wow okay well
yeah everything's going great with that
and yeah just a whirlwind and now it's
starting to get really real all right
now let's cut to commercial and come
back with our guests the very talented
Lance Bass
dude I've been having these crazy sweet
cravings lately honestly and uh I'm kind
of over my usual go twos you know like I
usually have like some kind of pretzels
or something like chocolate-covered you
know but I wish I could just eat like a
whole tub of cookie dough you ever feel
like that dude I eat whole tubs of
cookie dough all the time and that's not
a joke
now hold multiple cookie dough in one
sitting
what but a lot of people don't because
because the package says do not consider
all do you know that is raw egg and
flour but I've done a coli man I found a
way around that and this is this is true
it's called edible right and so it's a
cookie dough that is insanely delicious
flavors I'm not just talking chocolate
chip cookie I'm talking like cinnamon
cookie this snickerdoodle
you know snickerdoodle yeah they've
snicker and they leave the eggs and the
raw flour out of it so it's a healthy
thing to eat when everything's actually
made here in LA and they use only the
best stuff including Belgian chocolate
know she can just eat it and I get sick
it's crack it's like once you start like
you can't stop oh wow so you can be an
AAA and eat it yes you can and now we
are offering something special for our
our listeners if you want to try this
out which I'm serious you should try you
go to edible calm and that's Edie mm-hmm
ough ble calm hmm and we're giving up
there giving 15% off to our listeners
you know one of our listeners
well then use the the the code allegedly
mm-hmm the name of our show at the
checkout and you'll get 15% off and
that's Edie Oh ugh ble calm yeah now I'm
gonna eat I'm probably gonna eat two
tubs tonight no joke really two tubs is
that a like a euphemism for something no
too little too little tops are you
absolutely entire talk I just did re
yeah and would you think it's delicious
so everybody go to edible calm enter the
code allegedly get 50% off and enjoy
your summer and your
yeah and let us know let us know you
like it yeah all right welcome back and
this is me Matt and we have Jeff and
here's Lance Bass hey hard it was not to
jump into that conversation talk about
big brothers you're a big brother fan
fanatic throw a ball you've seen it all
yeah would you ever go on Big Brother
probably not if it wasn't being filmed
yeah I would kill in that game I'd win
that thing but no I don't want anyone to
see me 24/7 cuz you look you're
eventually gonna say something that
people aren't gonna like and Dumbledore
Oh buddy alright so here we are
allegedly with our guest Lance Bass and
Lance as I explained to you how our
special podcast goes we start with round
one which is our storytelling round and
Jeff and I each have three minutes to
tell a story about something that has
happened to us and you can judge it okay
and you can ask question I'm good at
judging alright yeah you can ask
questions through it if you want you can
whatever you want and then at the end
you'll have to pick a winner so I'll go
first I'm gonna talk about a story that
happened to me last week one of the
things that is not my friend is boredom
and the other thing that's not my friend
is grinder and when born boredom and
grinder go together it's Lord the head
so I talking to this one dude and he's
21 which is my thing but he's a
defensive lineman for a college team
right hey and he's out I looked him up
and did stuff about him and I don't
normally hook up but I was like when am
I gonna have this opportunity great what
do you want really bad that's all it is
just a hooker that guy you have in your
yeah I know anyways turn does it goes
above 25 on yours right not this guy 6 5
280 pounds sure so it was an experience
thing it was purely for the experience
he was visiting because he goes to
college in the East Coast he was
visiting so he's at his parents house
anyway so I went to his house and this
guy is a behemoth you know like like
looking at like Trek you know but much
better looking but well I hope so
dude and he wanted to get write down the
action and he first thing he did was
lifted me up never had this happen
before and threw me on the bed and I was
like that's cool and weird like this
into that it was definitely neat and I'm
like alright this is the experience I
wanted I guess so
it went south because everything goes
south for me and I'm figuratively and
literally mom if you're listening to
this one this is where you press pause
and then you come back in five minutes
so another thing has never happened to
me before and soul is every I'm like a
Larry David so I go with experience of
whatever or not they I always overthink
them and they [ __ ] things up and I
always looks awful so anyway the guy was
like this is very graphic where do you
want me to shoot right and not a camera
soon my story is horrible and I said I
don't care whatever and so he's kind of
any shot and he shot in my eye
oh never happened to me before never got
a burn that not only burn I panicked
like I was like I like try pushing him
off me I was like oh my god what did you
do and he's like what's wrong and I was
like shot in my eye and he's like calm
down calm down he's like trying to he's
like I was like what do I do get a warm
compress he's like my did you think your
eyeball was gonna get pregnant don't
know what a warm compress and I was like
I'm mourning after Visine even pretty
much and he's like calm down dude I was
like do you have diseases do you have
diseases and he was like no I don't have
diseases calm down and I was like
alright so he actually was very caring
and to think about that well it that was
the second thing that came into my head
after him nope third thing no pun
intended get it and so he actually took
me into the bathroom and he helped me
like wash it out on Wednesday and then
he said you know I I would probably
still get it looked at because I think
even healthy semen could cause problems
and I looked at him and I was like okay
and he's like do you want me to like
take you to a doctor or a hospital or
something I'm like if it's very sweet
actually
and I was like no no I'll be okay and so
at that point it was out but it was kind
of like clunky like it's gross but like
like shut you know like it was kind of
you know like almost if you got like
pink guy ish but like conjunctivitis
yeah like that it was like that but I
don't know if it was that or there's
just like semen in there anyway so I
went home and I you know washed it off
hundred times and I went to the store
and I bought one of those like I bought
washed things you know I was totally
over I probably like you're totally very
David though you were overboard and I'm
like freaking out like how do I use it
and I wash my out and everything was
fine that was my experience with the Oh
anyone you're a suspecting this wait I
rode here with him and I got no inkling
at all of what was about to happen it
was saving this mom if you're listening
shut it off when that's my shirt
probably went first you should have
thought this through I'm out with Jordan
we go to his club Bootsy bellows you're
familiar of course you know our buddy
works there and sometimes once in a
while celebrity stop by and some of the
celebrities I don't have no idea who
some of these celebrities are but this
time Dominick Cruz came by and if you
guys know Dominick Cruz no he's a UFC
fighter and he's uh he's a champion
actually right now I think it won fit
but that's like who you would recognize
totally totally so he no one in there
really knew who he was and I was like oh
my god is that Dominick Cruz you know
our friend was like yeah you know
Dominick Cruz I'm like yeah for sure
is he one of the good look in UFC he
actually is yeah yeah you would like him
and Brian stands is another guy so both
of them were there and I was I got super
excited I as you know he could drink
whatever you want over there and I'm
having fun and you know everyone started
just some celebrities moving in the
booth we're all having fun
and I was so excited so I was talking to
them they're like hey man you guys
should you should follow me on Instagram
and blah blah blah come check out the
fights and I was like yeah for sure I'm
like so excited I'm talking these guys
you know I'm all into the UFC and stuff
so if you know Bootsy bells how like
there's the mirrors all around right
where the DJ booth is you know so
there's one there's one where you could
sit back and lean against the mirrors of
course in that corner right right so I
was so excited that I thought I was in
that corner and I run up to Jordan and
as you know the DJ booth is right there
with the piano and everything like in
the middle of the whole club so
everyone's like having fun getting
drinks I run up to Jordan to go to jump
and sit on the booth which I think I'm
sitting and
flipped straight over I mean this is
like six feet in the air right into the
DJ pit oh right on my back boom oh my
feet go over my head everyone in the
whole booth looks over I had a beer and
it spilled over on my face none got my
eye on my back and it was like all I
remember is looking up I mean I didn't
get I think God I didn't get ya
I looked and everybody see heads I go
around like the booth and right
dude are you okay and I was wasn't one
please tell me you're dreaming Dominick
Cruz comes over I get up I'm like so
embarrassed I get up and Dominick Cruz
comes over he goes oh my god dude he
goes I don't get slammed that Hardin in
UFC are you okay I was so embarrassed
the rest of the night he's like hey man
I was like hey and I just like ran away
I could talk to Eddie why was there the
quintessential record scratch on yeah
you know that do the DJ's like bro you
okay man everybody there was like do
what happen did you like big brother
oh my god I think I don't know but there
was other people there who cares that's
what happened that is such a dude story
that's how it's better than like oh man
we went out met Nick Cannon and we went
out and smoke joints in his house and
back I mean that's how my Hollywood
nights alright so there's your time
Lance the power Falls teas in my hands
it's in your hands what about their very
very great stories thank you say you are
a good judge well I am I I think I am
I'm very fair yeah you look extra
handsome today by the way why thank you
extra bonus point for uh Jeff let me get
my eye ready I'm gonna have to award
504's for Jeff Schroeder over there
because I just love the the fact that um
you even know well of course you know
who this guy is new you see f UFC that's
college UFC man's guy went to UFC but
I'm gonna have to give one extra point
tomato points awarded to Matt just
because the curve got a 21-year old and
I think that's kind of nice
I'll show you this PA and and I and I
know you're gonna show me pictures later
which is gonna be
the reason I'm choosing you for this
faucet right now see the thing though I
was a little morning in that like I
expected like ripped like Jason Momoa
you know but it was a little like it was
linebacker and linebackers beefy boy it
was just tough you can tell me which
direction you were going in with these
stories so I could have I mean they
dirty dirty and now we move on to round
two with that which is our interview
segment where we'll take turns asking
you questions Lancer okay you are in the
hot seat all right after you did some
judging now I will go first and I'm just
gonna get this out of the way because
it's timely mm-hmm
Lou Pearlman yeah can you get it right
out of the way you were obviously Lou
Pearlman was one of the founders is it
he was our investor or an initial
investor and president of a record label
and our manager and six member of NSYNC
hmm and our cleaning lady okay well mr.
Pearlman passed away in prison recently
and I have a couple questions with that
how do you how does that make you feel
in all honesty because this is someone
that I know you guys had legal issues
with in the pass and it's not someone
who's a good guy necessarily no not at
all no so how does that make you feel uh
it couldn't conflicted emotions for sure
when I when I heard that it happened on
Saturday our manager Johnny Wright you
know emailed us all I was like hey you
know this is a room right now but you
know we think Lou Pearlman has passed
away and in prison and the first thing
you would think of that would come you
know the emotion that would come through
is like okay well great that's a good
comment okay that's that's common right
but the first thing that really hit me
was I felt sorry for him it was just I
mean dying in prison is probably one of
the worst ways you know to go I mean to
spend that that many years in prison and
I mean if you believe in karma then you
know karma definitely paid him back I
don't know
you know there's there's a lot of
stories about him now and you have to
understand loop Roman was with us at the
very beginning of our career he was you
know the
stur of NSYNC how we you know everyone
thinks that he put us together but he
didn't put us together he did put the
Backstreet Boys together they did a
search and put these boys together but
the reason we got together was Chris
Kirkpatrick he because the Backstreet
Boys were being put together and some of
his best friends were in the original
Backstreet Boys
he went to Lou Pearlman and said hey if
it's you know a group together will you
fund us and Lou said well as long as you
don't tell the Backstreet Boys then sure
you know I'll do it so he had to
secretly put together a band and you
know he found all of us and we you know
started the band and Lou secretively
scientist to his label the label didn't
even know we were so it started off a
little it was it was shady Shady um and
I really didn't understand that as a 16
year old I didn't really know what was
going on but I knew that we were just a
secret and even on on paper we were
called b5 at the record label because
they didn't want to let anyone know that
we existed I park it b5 sometimes yeah
live in b5 so you know so we weren't
really with him that long you know he
was a part of our first album he got us
our manager he helped find us our first
record you know deal but he wasn't
really he didn't influence us musically
he was very musically inclined he was
definitely a money guy and a shady money
guy at that once we found out so after
the first album we got rid of him we
haven't throw a huge lawsuit the last
time I saw him was in court when he was
trying to say that he was in sync and
not us 5 so you know he was just a shady
guy and never really reached out to you
know for forgiveness I believe in
forgiveness so the one thing that I can
say that I feel after knowing that he
has died is that I have forgiven you
know and I can that's the only thing I
can do I just say you know what karma
will get him in the end but I have to
forgive because I don't want this eating
at me at all
now of course there's a lot of things
you know that have come out after he
left us of a Ponzi scheme in Orlando
I mean rumors that he molested kids
never with you that's not ever no no and
you know and I've gone on record to say
that you know I felt something you know
I felt that he was probably a pedophile
he just had that that aura about him and
even at 16 years old you know he would
come up to us and grab our you know our
arms he like hey you know you've always
been working out and I knew that was
just too you know kind of feel my arms
and you know I knew that felt like but
were you working out and all fairness no
I was not which is why I'm like why are
you grabbing maybe not as you know so
but I felt kind of sorry for him even at
a young age I knew that oh this poor man
you know must be gay and has to hide it
and the only thing to kind of you know
make him feel good is to kind of be able
to fill someone's arms like how gross is
that you know and I just felt sorry for
Mike it was just so sad I've seen a lot
of tweets from people all Chris you Oh
Tom you know Backstreet Boys and they're
all kind of like say who he is r.i.p you
know whatever surprise is it doesn't
surprise you that nobody's like saying
out loud like [ __ ] this guy like well I
mean I've seen a lot of [ __ ] this guy
for sure on Twitter but from I got from
the artist yeah that's what I mean
do you think people are just I think
just people are trying to respect the
dead even if they were horrible people
you know you just can't speak ill of the
dead what else can they do I mean
they're not gonna hurt anyone like you
know if if something awful happened to
me like I did get molested by him I'd
probably have a different story I
probably would be like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you deserve to be in Hell
right now but that didn't happen to me
so the only thing that I have in my
heart is just forgiveness and in the end
I believe in karma
no well said Jeff do you have a subject
you'd like to broach now I do well could
you tell us about the new show that
you're doing now I mean yeah that's
charming is that what it's yes it's a
finding Prince to finding Prince Charlie
this is unload oh right its own logo its
premiering very soon September 8th ok
it's coming out in a couple weeks
Thursday nights at 8 o'clock I think we
follow RuPaul's Drag Race all-stars yes
where they get to vote each other off
that's it's gonna be a good RuPaul so
I've heard
oh yeah so I'm excited you're the first
that I'm actually able to say the date -
because I'm graduating by the way and
you're hosting this I'm hosting it on
the Chris Harrison show and what
dream job you are there's a bachelor yes
so I've seen the pictures of who just
happens to be ripped and gorgeous how do
you know the bachelor is we haven't
announced that you haven't no oh I think
I would like to crystal blue eyes and
his waist is like yeah this place is
like that yeah since this you know yes
that is that's finally I know the words
out that's true yeah he did leak that a
couple weeks ago yeah yeah yeah and so
he this guy's looking for love and it's
kind of like the bachelor and then
there's these other yeah it's a great
dating show look I love reality dating
shows from Tila Tequila to the bachelor
- bachelor in paradise I watched them
all so when I was asked to host this
thing it took me a millisecond say yeah
and you know this is the first all-gay
dating show right I mean this is history
being made and I can't believe it's
taking this long so yeah I mean it's I'm
excited for the show because it it's it
gives every element that I wanted to be
a part of there's a lot of heart in it
because logo has a lot riding on this
show they you know before the show even
airs people already have their their
preconceived you know notions of what
it's going to be oh they're all gonna
fall in love with each other they're all
gonna be screwing each other I mean it's
just that's the first thing you think of
right yeah and which is a total valid
thing I think that was actually my first
question so we could just go into that a
little bit so that was my first question
what's the keep these guys there see I'm
with nothing keeping them from hooking
up nothing and and they're there's no
rules in the house because we want it to
be real if two guys in if two suitors in
the house fall in love with each other
that's valid you know
that then they found love great you know
a good thing that our you know prince
charming figured out that they like each
other more than him and there you go
just beautiful but do you think that
happens on this show but it's totally
valid so did you film already oh yeah
we've you so you saw about a month ago
okay so how were the contestants were
they dead serious about meeting this
prince charming and because yeah that's
one of your it's about like you said
it's a valid point and it's a shame to
an extent I mean that everybody just
dismisses that
okay guys we're actually looking for
love
they're just thinking that everyone's
gonna [ __ ] each other inside right
there's temptation in there there's
alcohol I'm guessing they're all in its
guess just very similar to you they're
all in one house you know they're not
the bachelor is not always there so I
put myself in that situation cuz I am
looking for love would i but then I'm
man also you cannot be one of the twelve
no way but I second season no
realistically I would you know you see
what you're not it's not just one
bachelor that you have the opportunity
of there's 12 others that are in there
see so is there a screening process for
that like how serious these people were
I'm sure I mean I'm sure there's a any
bad yeah everyone going into the house
really wanted to find love because our
community did you get the crate like do
castle regular reality every single type
of personality you can think of alright
that's the other thing everyone always
has let me Gus you're gonna get an
all-white cast it's 25 years old with
eight packs wearing Speedos
I'm like no it's it's all over the board
yes there's some gorgeous men in the
house there's your average people in the
house there's your you know pudgy people
in the house in the house you've got
lots of dad bods but it's that's what I
loved about you know what they did with
this with this first season is they
really wanted to show everyone all the
you know different types of people in
this community and see which one our
bachelor
would connect with the most to an extent
the guy they picked as the bachelor
isn't watching or horse knows you wanted
look if we're gonna find Prince Charming
we're gonna you know cast a Prince
Charming they're gonna be gorgeous
successful a great heart wanting to
start a family I mean it's you're trying
to find the perfect guy so it is that
guy that the rumors are aboard that TMC
yes it is his name is Robert Sepulveda
jr. Sepulveda yeah Roberts boy he's
drove on him too now he was born in
Puerto Rico so we have and that's
another great thing about the show is uh
they really have a diverse cast you know
a lot of Latin black/white and you name
it it's all in the house and and that's
what I'm very proud of is that they they
really wanted to show a lot of diversity
do they all sleep you're just gonna
to find out would you have dated this
guy if you were single no I mean I mean
I think he's everyone's type
I guess waist is really thin it is a
very thin waist bizarre I was bizarre to
me that he looked almost like a cartoon
yes that in shape and his eyes were that
blue yeah he's he's when I first met him
on set I couldn't stop staring at his
like in his eyes you know I was just
like is that it's all natural oh yeah oh
really
Wow there we go you said you mentioned
two other shows yeah yeah I shot a fox
show that comes out in January which I'm
real excited about because it's it's a
it's a cooking show and I a lot of
people don't know this but my passion
really is cooking so Fox is bringing
this format from Australia I think it's
gonna be the team's the timeslot of
American Idol since it's gone now oh so
they're really putting in a lot of money
buying this show mean it's it's gonna be
a huge hit for them but it's called My
Kitchen Rules all right I guess we got
to go to number three now yeah it's I've
joined for the second season of this
show called dance-off juniors so I'm a
judge and these kids are may as a judge
as a judge yeah and every episode it's
three different kids and there's the
winner and the you know one kid wins
$5,000 but it was just so $5,000 their
mom's gonna take it anyway there you go
I want to ask I know you went to jc's
40th birthday last week two weeks ago
something like that it was August 8th is
his birthday so whatever that was we
I've seen it on in media and stuff tell
me what it was like how was it and this
is the Union everyone's but I mean I
know everybody's been talking about it
because it hasn't happened really it's
hard to get all five of us in a room is
it harder is it really conscious uh no
no it's just it's hard I mean we're just
so all over the place I mean half of us
live on the East Coast the other half
here on the west coast so it's really
hard I mean four of us get together a
lot that's just that fifth which for
which four of you get together a lot
well no actually I mean no we
I know what else know whatever no no
Justin hangs out a lot with us and it's
it's great we we have this group text
that we've been on you know for 10 years
now
really I mean if I'd love to get in
there if all these texts were printed
out and putting the Smithsonian I swear
to God there would be some good reading
because it is some yeah it's hilarious
what we every week we talk to each other
that there's group text so it's like we
day hasn't past that you know we haven't
that we've not grown up we're always
sixteen-year-old boys so that's exactly
what happened at Joey at JC's birthday
it was a very small intimate little
dinner party and about 30 of us and we
ended up just the five of us and our
significant others which is always fun
to see the wives and husbands you know
kind of hanging out with the group
because I love when my husband gets to
see how we are as brothers because I
mean we are brothers we love each other
we hate each other we have every emotion
known to man but it is fun to see them
really bonding with with our husbands
and my husband and wife someone else has
a husband by the way I don't want anyone
outright but you know we revert to being
16 again and the old you know crude
jokes and we all got wasted and it was a
good time was Jessica there yeah
everyone's there everybody it's a
question get asked over and over and
over and I don't know if this actually
gave some hope with this recent reunion
we're all together is there going to be
would you do it what's holding it back
except except oh I would I thought of
course I would do more music with these
guys I you know that's I love it it's
one of my favorite things to get on
stage with them I don't know if it will
ever happen I mean cuz all the shit's
happening now like Oh towns back
whatever fact is the back street dude
they got a residency now in Vegas no I
thought that was coming out I wish
they'd be amazing for them New Kids on
the Block just went out again I need
ninety one reasons the thing is they
they they've all been touring for many
years and
I mean they haven't stopped it's just
people just think that everyone broke up
but we're the only group to really have
stopped
O'Town did too for a while can I um but
yeah I mean none of them have Justin
Timberlake that's the problem
no I mean Justin was just an anomaly he
you know he we went on a six-month
hiatus he's like I'm gonna try the solo
album I doubt it'll work then we'll come
back in six months and do the next album
we're still waiting on the next album it
just did not stop yeah like do you ever
drive honest and you're not gonna you
can't answer honestly but you ever
driving pretty like I got this feeling
like you son of them you know well that
song is my favorite song of his I like
you're too nice of a guy to think that
no I you know is it disappointing we
never did the new NSYNC album yes of
course I spent months writing that thing
and I never got to record the songs that
I had spent a lot of time on so that was
disappointing but I mean you can't you
can't deny the fact I mean we we had no
idea that his career was gonna blow up
like that and there was no there was no
stopping it and then you have to
understand that yeah even if Justin
wanted to do another instinct album he
also has hundreds of employees that
don't want it to happen because they
make nothing off of it and it's gonna
delay their next Justin them so you know
there's a lot of people you know
stopping that well it doesn't suck you
guys getting together for maybe one
bonus track I'm like a Justin Turner
like album well I mean who knows I mean
yeah if it's an instinct song that we
put together for a soundtrack or you
know we're getting our star on the Walk
of Fame is awesome you know we're gonna
be all together for that bass below it I
mean you're already blown up my god
would you would you ever replace someone
if one no we think we talked about that
we discussed that we've discussed that
with Justin you know and Justin was
saying he even said guys I don't want to
do something you know the four of you
coming go right ahead but we ultimately
all decided it's just not in sync
without all right guys it just wouldn't
have you ever thought of [ __ ] marry kill
with the in sinkers I could I get that a
lot really actually and it's it's kind
of gross to think about
think about that it's you know it's like
saying you know [ __ ] marry kill you know
for your four brothers if you had four
brothers right you know it's like how do
you it's kind of gross brother doesn't
look like Justin Timberlake is not
attracted to even from day one I've been
gay my whole life even joining the group
I really had no attraction to any of
them yeah that was one of my questions
that is no no ones don't think anyone's
ever asked me did you ever cash in on
like boyband ass you know that term yeah
did you never catch it and you never got
with any girls during that whole I did
of course because I felt like I had to I
mean when all eyes are on you you you
played the game
your brother's your boy the boy in sync
members they didn't know at first I
don't get that close without maybe
starting to assume certain things so
you're not a gold star gay I am NOT a
gold star gay yeah sorry about that I
wish I was so alone no I mean I I
actually wish I were because it wasn't a
well no I mean just I just don't think
it was fair to the girlfriends I had you
know because you know what we're
teenagers so I mean it's right
everyone's whatever still try and figure
out who they are but I knew that I was
gay at that point and that I didn't
enjoy that right and well let's do [ __ ]
marry kill with your good friend kris
Jenner's kids with her kids Kim Khloe
Kim Kris way to the Buddha Jenner
maybe we could put the Jenners in there
too to make it oh the boys like Brody
and the Jenner / Kardashians and Caitlyn
and everybody okay everybody's the whole
thing of all of them of all of them a
Kardashian [ __ ] marry kill
I'm sure this game has never been played
before I know well if I can choose that
I mean of course I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to - [ __ ] Brody I mean that's yeah
that's the the good one Mary I would
probably wait you're Kate and you have
to kill one okay Mary I would go with
mmm this might be an odd one for you
but I think I would say Courtney because
I just think she's hilarious okay
so you see having the best time with her
you know yeah you would think Chloe
right cuz that that would I would say
your answer to though
yeah Jeff's not a big Chloe fan no well
I just have a problem with I don't have
a problem with her but I don't even know
her to be honest with you but I when
someone keeps saying I'm the normal one
when you keep saying that you're not the
normal one yeah I mean Chloe yeah I mean
she would be fun to it go out with and
yeah I love Chloe but Courtney and I
share the most friends so I know that we
would probably have they would have a
better marriage gotcha yeah but no I was
trying to explain to Jeff the whole
Caitlyn thing yeah it's difficult it's
how I feel I didn't understand it
what about Luke Romo just mixed emotions
you know right
she's a very PI mean she's done
something great and take steps forward
reviews yeah are very antiquated and
don't seem to fit no I didn't understand
that when you were telling me in the car
I had no idea well the visibility she's
brought to the transgender community is
an incredible I mean no one could have
brought that much attention in such
positively pioneer to a community new
thing however however she is a very
strong Republican and has some really
messed up views that don't really make
sense with her lifestyle like which is
just confusing and and and I just I
think there's she's just very uneducated
in a lot of a lot of areas so if she the
one you're gonna kill you can kill you
know what I'm going to kill Kylie
because I am so pissed that a girl can
make a hundred million dollars a month
off damn lipstick there that's not fair
alright I like that one that was it but
you are good friends with Chris one of
my besties yeah but we're doing a show
together which I'm very excited about
but it's you know Robin Antin
yeah she stated the Pussycat Dolls and a
few other girl bands out there so her
and I are doing the show where I'm in
charge of the boy house and she's in
charge of the girl house and it's this
competition to see who can build a
better band a boy band or girl band in
America votes to see who they want the
next great American band to be well you
already got their first vote right here
Lance yeah you're gonna be from a voice
oh yeah and then Kris Jenner has always
wanted to manage oh yeah and she's you
know she wants to branch out and go into
music she I think she'd be great at it I
mean so she's our you know our lead
judge it's like being friends with
someone like that
who is so everywhere that family is
Jagger how do you even you know it was
you know I've been friends with them and
especially Chris for years before they
kind of blew up and became their
Kardashian's I I met her when Kim did my
season of Dancing with the Stars and Kim
was voted off second week so Chris and I
bonded because she had to choose someone
else to pull for and she was hosting the
red carpets for et or whatever and so we
you know she became my mother basically
like mean she was just it was like
family to me so it's been interesting to
watch that kind of Empire grow and grow
and grow and go through the craziest
things from Lamar - Catelynn - I mean do
these lips today it's just it doesn't
stop and to see how she's really managed
the whole empire they're laughing all
the way to the bank that's true I mean
she takes heat people manipulative in
the past and that jeez do you see those
strings being pulled know those kids
know exactly what they want to do and
she just does what they say she will
guide them and there's a lot of things
she doesn't really agree with some steps
they want to take but she's always very
supportive and yeah she's a good mama
drew not a bad partner to have on a show
we know that I have some random
questions here and there will do I'm out
of a candy fast one have you ever seen
Justin naked that I've seen all the boys
naked yes I have is it awesome
again gross oh but people would not be
disappointed in any other guys yeah okay
you'd have fun with that
next you have talked about how you get
it Andy Cohen once well I would never
say today - no no that's we've we've
definitely made out you know yeah who
else give us one more slight celebrity
yeah celebrity that I've that I've made
out where yes yes danielle fishel know
everybody knows that one and I question
the celebrity I'm just that was mean I I
mean there's Ricky Ricky night wish
Ricky never Ricky Martin every oh god I
wish do you know that's my tight
especially back true late nineties /
2000s we do like like yeah when you guys
were both did you ever work on that like
no right again we were both so far in
the closet that's true yeah but you know
we did many shows together so you know
we we got to know each other but we may
not that way now I wish I mean I can't I
mean there really is no there is your
cell I mean there there's there's one
good one that that could never tell you
about cuz they're not that's the one
because I would never out no that would
be a no no no but there I mean is it
Jack Nicholson no I mean it's it's you
would imagine there's a lot of people of
course in the closet in this business um
but you would never imagine how many
people how when that happens because
this is you're kind of describing my
fantasy right now it's a little bit how
does that even come across do you guys
like you're just in a with this big
celebrity and then it just naturally
happens or make some other smooth they
do it over here
no way yeah in this one that they may
and I was very taken aback how Ford they
were publicly because they are very very
a lister and was very is very obvious
what they're doing away alright now we
just want to know who did I know it's
about publicly
you mean as far as anti no no no no just
hitting on me in pain Oh in public yeah
not like behind hit
doors it was yeah like in a car in front
of their friends yeah Wow
so their friends must know I mean I
interesting oh I think I was just gonna
say see man I turn wheels turning over
there no I know but he won't do he won't
blow it up but after I mean my friends
know the story because it's one of my
favorite stories to tell when I'm drunk
okay fair enough
and then number three was she talked
about wanting kids soon yeah soon assume
um I mean just like Jeff said I mean
there's no really there's never a time
to really you know you have to have a
kid or I just it's happened you guys
just gotta jump in jump in but not with
us yeah I know like now you planning of
course but there's no there's no perfect
time to do it and I kept telling myself
in the last few years well I want to
make sure you know when if this show
gets picked up then I know I'll be in LA
for the next five years so then that'll
be the time but then you know it's never
you'll never do it if you did people
tell me that too if you do that you'll
never exactly ever and that's what I've
come across the last three years because
all my friends are having their kids and
and I want my kids to kind of able to
grow up with them and now they're
getting on their second kid and I'm
still not on my first like dammit
so I imagine we would probably start the
process early next year okay and what's
the process process is I there's an
amazing company that a lot of people
have been using a Neil Patrick and
everyone have used this company and they
set you up with a surrogate and there's
all different ways of doing it
surrogates that you never have to meet
which of course I want to I want them in
my life right I want to know who was
donating the egg I mean you can donate
an egg put it in someone else I mean you
can have twins you can make sure that
one is mine and one is Michael's I mean
there's really there's so much you can
do that's the way I would go
it's yeah I mean if you want to go ahead
and just get it all John I'm sure I
think it's like fifty thousand a kid
Kardashian but I mean it's not this is
show the will here I mean straight
people been doing this for years you
know
but yeah I'm excited because I know
Michael will be the best dad ever it's
one of the reasons I wanted to marry him
so I'm excited to you know to start this
family because I think all of us
selfishly want to try to raise the best
kid possible just so that we can have a
better person in this world you know
helping out and so I hope to raise some
good kids that will leave a good mark in
this world
well giddyup buddy because mine's coming
in October alright well that wraps up my
questions yeah I just have one more you
have done so much in this business what
are you most proud of up to this point
um Wow what am I most proud of I mean
the work with NSYNC I think is probably
what I'm the most proud of just because
we worked our asses off and and no one
will understand exactly what we went
through except us five and I love that
we have that bond and and I just think
we you know we made music that I was
proud of and I think that we did it in a
way that I can be proud of too that we
you know that we were nice about it that
we we didn't change really we didn't
turn into [ __ ] I'm proud of those
guys for still being who they are
because when you go through something
like that you can easily forget what
reality is and I was just proud to have
for my best friends you know keep me
down to earth so there was never a
drunken night or you're like hey I'm
gonna try to kiss one of them or
something you know if there was a Latino
in the group artisan if you were in
menudo
yeah menudo that would've been a
different story okay fair enough fair
enough all right well that wraps up
round 2
power falls to you oh you have to pick a
winner upset around I know I Jeff I feel
really bad about this but Matt you had
some good question person so now we move
to round three
so round three what we're going to do is
each pitch to you an idea for a new man
band okay perfect okay
hey this is Anne so there will be five
don't take it too serious at least for
my end mine either there will be five
points we have to give you a name a hit
song title a new style that it it
launches like a trend clothing hair
anything like that yeah and I'm not just
a man that they have on the riders yes
and lastly who the biggest celebrity
affair would be with one of the the lead
singer and all right so we can go whoo
let's go y'all gonna build it in front
of me before this we each answered the
band name would you want to go 1 1 1 1
yes for sure okay so who would use Man
Man do you want to know first ah let's
start with you Matt okay this goes in
with my round one the band's name is
uncut and the slogan is Five Guys
foreskin mine are way more childish so
my if you pick me ours and our boy Ben
name would be Lansing the boils if you
picked mad to be Lansing the Moyles well
it all goes back to uncut and cut you're
cuttin you're cutting everything your
lancing a boil we're on the same way
exactly my hit song would be you had me
at smegma my our hit song for me would
be can't stop the poppin or dirty pop
which is already used if it was yours
I'll be bristling you we did not discuss
this we did not at all we didn't know
but I like okay the new style that uncut
would spark our hoodies oh you okay you
got that hoodies would come into style
because yeah I get you you got a whole
theme going I stopped it I was gonna go
with the theme and I thought I can't
keep going with this so I thought a good
one what to do is like bring back the
old friar look okay I like with totally
bizarre but bedazzles out like robes and
you get that crazy haircut okay well
it's it's almost like the Caesar cut in
the 90s but like reverb and yeah reverse
what if Bieber did that I wonder if
Bieber did something like that if it
would catch on because that is a pretty
horrible
remember those one there hasn't been
done remember those long long t-shirts
Bieber's started wearing I'm like what
the hell is this this will never come in
look what's in ya know is that in yeah
it's very no no and he's trying to pull
that grunge look back and he was were
getting off-topic
he loves Bieber I love you would you
blow Bieber I was gonna go back to the
hole it's a good listen that's a good
first single blowing baby no and Bieber
I think you would I know I wouldn't blow
beer I think you I wouldn't blow Bieber
all right first of all I would like to
hang out we were so young yeah I mean
like I thought we'd be cool but I'm not
cool I'm dadbod you know what I mean I
couldn't even hang and not a problem
with he's 21 right like yeah he's young
and not only is he 21 but he's really
mentally prob about 15 because right you
know kid stars they get stunted they
really do like I I'm still 18 mentally
and everything well so am i but I'm not
even a star so you like you look at him
and you sympathize I can sympathize and
somewhat of course I think that with him
I think he's he's been able to learn his
lesson a few too many times yes
and I'd like to see him really you know
get his [ __ ] together every part I'd
like hung out with him hung out with one
Tom yeah yeah and he was super super
sweet yeah yeah so I mean I felt bad for
him yeah I think it's a lot I don't know
that word I mean it's the same for you
but like having that many people
especially now with like social media is
even crazier than I know you guys like
what when you guys would show up
somewhere you guys would shut it down I
mean with social media now and stuff
like that needs a good blow job
good here's the thing about him being
like a soul Lord because I saw the same
thing happen with Britney
your solo it's so much harder Michael
Jackson all these people it's everyone's
a yes-man and no one tells you no so you
are so warped about what reality is and
I don't think Bieber has real friends
around him I think his only true friend
is probably Scooter Braun only you know
or I mean I mean how I mean his homilies
probably not even that I don't wait
though no for him and you guys got the
bounce stuff off each other yeah you
know we just kept us down to earth and I
just don't think he has many real
friends you know you hang out with your
dancers or your makeup artists that type
of stuff and you know they can be very
jaded themselves and kind of lead you
down the wrong road and all you want to
do as a kid artist is just be cool and
let people like you especially in the
industry so you can you can definitely
stray well you know what before we go to
this thing since you mentioned Britney I
want to ask do you would you have
guessed that she would be where she is
right now back when you knew and she's
got a residency in Vegas she's got kids
she's got her [ __ ] together seemingly
would you have guessed that does that uh
yeah I mean I I went through some oh of
course she went through you know a lot
and I don't know exactly mean I'm sure
you know the what she went through like
in her early 20s was either like bipolar
nurse's you know something was was and
that use and that always happens around
that age you know if that's gonna happen
to your brain that hits around you know
21 and and that's what we saw so kudos
to her and the people around her to
getting her back on track and and being
able to do the things she loves because
she loves being onstage she loves
teaching dance to kids I mean it's it's
so sweet to see what she's doing and and
this new album I don't know if you've
heard it but it is I think the best
album she's ever done alright on that
one we'll go to number four words
obnoxious demands right yeah okay um
mine it's ironic that it goes with yours
but no knives are allowed in the
dressing room oh really
for the uncut thing Stampede yeah I
forgot about the theme I forgot about
the theme no one's really obnoxious only
forks and spoons everyone alright mine
is I want us to be comfortable because
we
getting older and we're gonna be on our
feet a lot so designer orthotics all
right and lastly the huge celebrity
effect listen you're gonna be
comfortable in my band nice I trust me I
got rollers coming for the shoes just I
wear natives every day
the huge celebrity affair and this is
only because I'm on a campaign to get
him on our show is Scott Eastwood okay
my tweet really he's coming on he's
coming on I was just gonna go with
someone I right up your alley you might
like this one
I would super chef Rachael Ray groupie
to celebrity host yeah cook for
everybody it's all gonna be comfortable
we're gonna be fat okay we're out like
we're going this I did okay so those are
two very different bands and I'm
guessing I'm guessing Matt's gonna break
away at some point now a solo career
I'm sticking around I'm one of the boys
so I have to pick one I can't just pick
elements no you had one great element
yes to make wine half of yours Jeff I
mean amazing in half of yours Matt
amazing if you give me three quarters in
one quarter Matt I'll let us I'll let us
merge I'm gonna have to go with Jeff on
this one oh you're just uncut biased
there's trust me I've dated only
Brazilians in my life so uh there you go
may you think yeah you've lost all your
edge that's gonna be a dad now 37 years
old you don't need edge well if you want
to come on tour with uncut and open up
for us we could love to have you
alright so ergo because there were three
rounds mmm Jeff won one mm-hmm I went to
mm-hmm
what does that mean well see I was told
there was no math but I think yeah you
win Matt yeah
finally you're a winner Oh finally I'm
still gonna go home and eat cookie dough
by myself speaking of which what is this
cookie dough that I see over there
because so one of our sponsors is called
edible and so edible is a company that
makes cookie dough how come I never
spoon in my show tubs yeah and they make
every freaking kind from here we have
chocolate chip and birthday bash and so
it has no flour and no eggs so it's like
that health so it's vegan
it's vegan yeah and you know the
Salmonella with the right so you can eat
it as is you can put it in even though
you know we all eat the dough oh we all
eat the dough but this way you can feel
a little better like it's not real
ingredients - I know like oh they have a
red velvet cookie dough oh dude they
have everything if snickerdoodle
oatmeal raisin chocolate chip cookie
dough birthday bash they have s'mores
eat some of this right yeah no you are
did I eat it all I did I got one for
myself and I ate a little before I came
this guy goes like crazy at the yogurt
stand I do it's it's delicious really
great yeah you just eat it you just why
would you want to make him two cookies
when you can just eat the dough right
there's so much work I put this in my
shake and you can go on edible calm II
do ugh BL e OS clever and adobo yeah
exactly can use you can when you check
out
use the code allegedly and you will get
15% off your order
now how do you spell alleged yeah you
know that was my question I didn't want
to look like that guy I swear to God I
was like you need a better promo code al
le GED ly one of my favorite things my
favorite Jeff and Jordan stories ever is
I went over to their house one time and
there was a pot of grease like cooking
grease that was left over and she wrote
a note to him that said don't drink the
grease but it was GRE ECE don't say that
I love it don't drink the grease all
right Oh Bob so yes edibles enjoy these
yes please everybody order your edible
and dude thank you so much for coming on
finally dude I hope you had fun Jeff
thank you for filling in thank you I'm
sorry that you lost I knew you I knew
this was gonna be a big deal of you
there's some reason I was coming up
these questions I'm like better but it
definitely you bail you built the best
boy band yeah I did yeah yeah that's
that's the real one so I guess it's
Lansing the boils the oils so weekend
September 8th September it's a no-go
Thursday night 8 o'clock
meet charming me finding my prince
charming its I'm telling you people are
gonna be having viewing parties the
straight women are going to die over it
this sure interesting I mean that
they're they're gonna freak you know
straight women who watch gay porn have
you heard of that I have heard of that
yes our thing to me yeah I don't get it
I don't get it there's a lot of weird
stuff in a porn world that's true
and then kitchen rules my kitchen my
kitchen rules in January on Fox January
and the other show dance-off juniors
will premiere in October I just don't
know when but it's gonna go 90 days my
form the Kris Jenner show is in the
making it's in the making so hopefully
we'll get that out by next fall man and
expect kids any day now and hopefully
dude you've got your busy a little bit
so we're glad to let you squeeze listen
absolutely always good to see you no
better guy for all the success man oh
and thank you everybody for listening
again I'm a twice with our co-hosts it's
me Jeff Schroeder hey thank you and
we'll see you next